all right so i've been working at aws
for two years now and the one question
that i've been asked over a hundred
times on this channel is do i need
coding skills to learn aws and land a
job as a solutions architect so i
started off at aws as an intern in 2020
with zero certifications and a pretty
basic level of coding experience at the
time i had two goals build my skills in
aws through certifications and land a
job as a solutions architect after my
internship i honestly had the same
doubts at the time i was thinking do i
need to learn python and java before i
even start studying for adb
certifications and if i do land a job as
a solutions architect am i going to be
expected to know how to code so as
someone who has now gotten five aws
certifications and is working full-time
as an associate solutions architect i
decided to make this video to help you
understand whether or not you need to
learn how to code before you start
studying for aws certifications and
becoming a solutions architect i've also
asked some more senior solutions
architects at aws to provide their input
so make sure you stay until the end of
this video to get a full understanding
okay so the short answer is no you don't
really need to know how to code to learn
aws and become a solutions architect the
long answer is it really depends now let
me tell you why to understand this
you'll need to know what a solutions
architect actually does and aws
solutions architect is a trusted
technical advisor for customers as they
go along their journey with using the
cloud on a day-to-day basis solutions
architects could be performing
architectural reviews providing
recommendations to customers based on
their business and technical goals or
just helping customers understand aws
better by running workshops and speaking
at conferences so from my personal
experience as a solutions architect at
aws i would say that we're rarely
required to sit down and code up a full
application we provide high-level
architectural advice to the customers
rather than inspecting the company's
application code having a coding
background might have been something
you've seen in job descriptions as a
preferred qualification but it's not a
strong prerequisite for being an aws
solutions architect all that being said
though many solutions architects at aws
do come from a technical background so
for example they were previously a
software developer in another company
and they like to use coding to help
customers better visualize the solution
for example if a solutions architect is
recommending a customer build a 3t web
application using amazon ec2 they could
code the front end to show customers a
landing page of what the website will
look like as an aws solutions architect
building these kinds of proof of
concepts can be beneficial but if you
don't know how to code you can also
leverage existing resources and
blueprints to demonstrate the solution
to your customer coding honestly is not
too important when it comes to being an
aws solutions architect i'll be making
another video very soon on the top
skills required to become an effective
solutions architect so make sure you
subscribe to this channel to stay
updated now you might be wondering okay
so if coding is not required to become a
solutions architect how about for aws
certifications do i need coding
knowledge to prepare for my cloud
practitioner or solutions arctic
associate exam if we look at the exam
guide you'll see that programming and
coding isn't mentioned at all instead
the focus is on the ability to design
and implement distributed systems on aws
of course coding skills will come in
handy when you're learning about aws
services that do require coding for
example aws lambda which is a serverless
compute service that runs code in
response to events and triggers but aws
certifications will mainly test you on
features of these services and how they
can be used alongside other aws services
to help users meet technical and
business requirements so long story
short if you know how to code in python
or java it will be helpful when you come
across services like aws slander but
it's not something you need to know
before preparing for an aws
certification and just to make sure what
i'm saying is not completely untrue or
super biased i've asked the opinion of
some of my colleagues to provide their
perspectives on whether coding is
required
i don't think coding is a prerequisite
but it definitely helps if you're
designing a solution for a customer and
you're familiar with the ins and outs of
how different paths might be built it
will help you make more informed
decisions aws is a big platform we have
lots of services that don't require
coding knowing how to code will
definitely help you better relate to
customers who are very technical but
because you won't be expected to build
any production systems for the customers
you can get away with not knowing much
coding so in summary you don't need to
learn a programming language before you
start your cloud learning journey and
becoming a solutions architect however
coding can help students better
understand the aws platform and enable
solutions architects to build stronger
relationships with customers alright so
this brings us to the end of this video
thank you so much for watching please
give this video a like if you got
something out of it and if you have any
other questions leave it down below and
i'll get back to you alright bye for now